i just wanted to be an engineering away
from other people i didn't want to be
near press i just wanted to work on more
designs i could design after design
after design of the design i did
andy wanted to share
all of the schematics and how everything
not from apple this company when the
money got put in we had to incorporate
and i was forced to leave
hewlett-packard where i had determined i
would be an engineer for life engineers
are good politicians aren't management
is politicians striving for different
job positions and and having to say bad
things about people and i couldn't do
that but i could do engineering
so um um what were you saying well i
just did because i i i learned this that
you had the the apple ii was expandable
with the eight slots oh okay coming on
yes coming on for designing the products
um
they were all mine the apple one apple
ii nobody helped i did all the hardware
all the software when i look back to how
much software i did i look back now my
old designs and i say how could i ever
have had the energy to do that and how
could i have come up with things that
were so far out of the books so far out
of the books color
our first logo was six colors you might
wonder why
and it's because the apple ii computer i
design games for atari like breakout a
game would be a hundred chips and a
thousand wires and an engineer like me
would have to keep track of every wire
it might take six months to make a new
game prototype
the apple ii computer was the first time
ever that arcade games it was um arcade
games were being started by atari right
here in los gatos california where we
are today um and uh i could go down
there and learn to play games earlier
and steve jobs would be wiring up my
design for breakout we delivered a
working breakout but
the apple ii computer was the first time
ever that arcade games were color
and the first time ever they were
software a nine-year-old kid could write
a good game for the day in one day one
day in basic
this was a change for gaming as much as
for computers that was a machine and
where it all came from was i was on the
atari floor and i thought man it'll be
neat if someday these games are in color
it would be beautiful
and then my head went back i was an
analog engineer i was a television
engineer too i went back to how color is
a sine wave on a wire that goes at a
certain exact right speed and it shows
up as red
if it's a little later in time it's blue
you know and that sort of thing and all
of a sudden i know there's there's books
and books on mathematics differential
calculus to design these circuits how
all these you know
existential waves and mathematics
created color tv their books on it
and i just said what if you took a
little number out of a computer that's
ones and zeros right out of the computer
memory and you put it on a wire into the
tv if the ones and zeros got fed at the
right rate i knew every color tv would
think it was color
never could any book have talked about
that little simple simple approach just
a pixel in a certain spot shows up as
green and a pixel the next spot over
shows up as red
i mean
um that was i mean that was that was
kind of amazing but i just thought that
way i don't know where these ideas came
from one after another after another for
about 10 years in my life and even
before apple
um right and you're starting with the
blue box you're just laying in bed
thinking about this like oh my god i
have to put this in the oh no i didn't
sleep for four days and nights doing
breakup for atari this was not possible
even for me to do in four days
so your head but if you're not sleepy if
you're if you're not getting to sleep
your head drifts off in weird tangents
you know in between standing up you
might sleep a little bit whatever it's
called and that's where this this color
idea had popped in just i'm start
thinking about it in my head and seeing
the the solution that wound up being uh
you know a huge part of apple and when
you come up with these ideas you want to
share publicly with everybody like what
the idea is and how to replicate it not
exactly i was in a club of people
stanford professors on down all sorts of
people that weren't rich and wealthy but
they're talking about if we ever had our
own computers it's getting close to the
price with a microprocessor we could
afford our own computers and they were
trying to build kits that weren't even
useful computers they were something i
built five years before the matter of
fact right when i met steve jobs i was
building a computer my own design
and they were trying to do it the wrong
way and i wanted things that were human
keyboard a typewriter's human a keyboard
and a display and i already learned that
my tv could be a display for pong you
know in games like that breakout but i'd
also then gone and made my tv a terminal
i made it so it could actually show
letter words and connect over the over
the phone line to a thing a new thing
called the arpanet
what is the arpanet
today it's the internet yeah they were
on that time there were only six
computers on the arpanet started by the
us government to put far away computers
and i could dial a number in palo alto
and then i could log onto the artbanet
and then i could
see a list of six computers and i could
pick one at mit and go there and then it
would say do you want to log in as a
guest or as a as a user guest i didn't
have accounts
and then i'd get on i could read files
and i could play games like chess and
this was a terminal i'd built
and that was one step closer to the
computer now in the club i finally found
out what a microprocessor was i hadn't
looked at them since the early ones
which are too weak for me i like
computers
and this microprocessor i took home a
data sheet oh my gosh the microprocessor
is like all of the computers i designed
in high school one after another after
another another note that's how i got so
skilled and good at making them a few
parts and i said oh my gosh i know how
to i'm going to have my own computer now
problem is i couldn't afford 400 for an
intel microprocessor
and then i found i could get one from
hewlett-packard where i worked for forty
dollars a motorola one so i designed my
whole thing on the drafting table for
the motorola processor and basically i
was taking that terminal it could talk
to a far away computer and it could type
back to my tv from mit
i just put my own computer the brains as
the microprocessor
and the memory had to be dynamic memory
everybody else was copying intel data
sheets on a data sheet with with lines
on paper you can only show
microprocessor has address one going to
address one on a chip address two going
to address two you only show straight
wires that's static ram cost four times
as much it was going to make getting a
useful computer a 4k computer that could
run a programming language out of the
range of normal humans no i put in the
dynamograms one-fourth as many chips i
always count things by chips and yes
what's what is a dynamic ram compared to
a static ram
it forgets everything it knows every bit
in the chip gets forgotten in two
thousandth of a second
so you have to get in and supply some
extra signals to make sure it it
triggers basically every row or every
column in the chip to make sure it reads
and rewrites its own data every two
thousandth of a second and that takes
some chips
but one of the things it takes is a
counter that goes this row and then that
row and that row and that rope counter i
already had counters for horizontal and
vertical on the tv i just reused them a
second time i always did everything i
could to be clever tricks today you'd
call it hacking but um
you know i
anyway so anyway i had the right device
and i took it down this was called um it
didn't have a name there's no company
steve jobs was out of town he didn't
know it existed so i took it to the
homebrew computer club
and i passed out schematics to everyone
in the club here's how you can build it
here are the chips you use here's the
code that i wrote for it and um
everyone in the club i passed it out but
everybody looking over my shoulders had
seen computers of the past with all
these switches and lights
and the computer of the future was the
the this became the apple one eventually
and from that point on no computer was
built without a keyboard and a video
display that was a turning point in
history but i didn't didn't own it i'd
given it away public domain because i
wanted to start the revolution these are
the people that are going to start the
revolution give them the give them the
tools to do it and then steve came into
town and it's the opposite of what a
movie shows there's a movie with ashton
kutcher
see comes and finds me in a basement a
big geek and he calls me to a club to
show it off to real people
what a farce he's never been to the club
i've been there every day since it
started i was a hero at the club i was
like here at the club passing my stuff
around showing it off and uh took him
down to see the interest in it you know
my tv and
the my board and keyboards and wiring
and lots of stuff osha would not have
liked
transformers with bare wires exposed but
took it down he saw the interest in
that's when he said we should start a
company
and what he proposed was not a computer
company it was a company to make
something he had understood from
something he'd done before in his life
make a pc board for twenty dollars then
people can get chips from their
employers plug the chips in and it's all
soldered it's all done they don't have
to hook wire to wire to wire to wire
that big mess instead of two weeks they
build it in one day
and we'll build the pc boards for twenty
dollars we'll sell them for forty when
you have no money no bank accounts no
rich relatives that's how you have to
think what can we do today with what we
have and that was our start
and um and it sprung and it went further
and further now hewlett packard i
offered it to them first the personal
computer i loved my company and i wanted
them to build it but they turned me down
five times
five times for the personal computer
they were just like we just don't see a
future there wouldn't have been a future
if they'd done it crazy the reason is is
they wouldn't have built a fun machine
that could play games they would have
built back then hewlett-packard only
built machines that engineers used you
know with dials and switches and power
supplies and cables
only for engineers they would have built
a boring dumb computer that engineers
could have a little tiny black and white
screen chiclets and they eventually
started a program on my floor in the lab
to do that and i had just built a device
with microprocessors that they were
using with dynamic rams they were going
to use they had five guys assigned to
writing the basic language i'd written
one all myself on mine
and they wouldn't let me on the project
even
so they turned down the personal
computer and you
built the first personal computer the
first really well the first really good
the apple one
was not
you know very quickly was not going to
be the substance of our of our life but
we got a 50 000 order
for pc boards with chips on them we
didn't have 50 000
we had to borrow 5000 from a friend and
we got the parts on 30 days credit built
the computers up delivered them and got
paid cash in 10 days we had 30 days to
pay for the parts and that's what you do
when you have no money you just i mean
steve jobs was a brilliant brilliant at
finding the ways that we could do
something make a step and at this but
that was before that was apple one
before we ever shipped the apple one
we were secretly showing my apple ii to
people that back in atlantic city they
had a show called pc76 and we didn't
want any of these other little startup
companies to see what we had so we went
down late at night when they were all
gone and there was just one guy there
with a projector i wanted to see if it
works on a projection tv was that new is
this is my color gonna my color output
gonna work on a projection tv and we
hooked it up with that guy and we did
and that guy was seeing all
the things that young people were trying
to bring to the world as computers and
he said this is the one i want
you know we always knew
that was the apple ii so we were and we
were just showing off the apple one we
hadn't shipped one yet so we knew the
apple ii was our our future for a big
company wow that was the one the app
because the apple one wasn't designed as
a wozniak computer it was a wasak
terminal for the arpanet modified into a
computer a little but not really
designed as a computer
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]